how does it a playful things go to socks
go so quickly today we the test friends
are at rise nation which means climbing
ladders I don't know what's gonna happen
today the one thing I'm sure of is I'm
gonna hustle I've heard that this is
really intense but I'm hoping that
because I still exercise regularly it
won't be too bad not really I really
know much about this I saw a picture of
it it kind of look like hell I'm not
someone that exercises at all but
everyone here has like very great 100%
smiles and that's very reassuring
it's I really hope Brian will spare us
all his grouting I make noise and I
workout because I'm an expressive dude a
half hour here fitting these machines
yeah so what is rise nation rise a ssin
is a 30 minute cardio class I
incorporates full-body which then the
whole thing on the burst of climbers so
pretty much you're fighting gravity it's
like an endless ladder if you want to
think of it that way
I hear Bradley Cooper does this pretty
ripped so rips he's a handsome guy is
obsessed with Bradley Cooper he's a big
Cooper head I would like to have his
muscles if I could we're gonna hold onto
both handles
yup hips are gonna go back right Devon
the superhuman was telling us to do
these moves where you would have to like
we change up the speed sometimes you do
these like really like intense like rip
through motions if you think of going
full length and just using a little bit
more energy okay
looks kind of like this so Devon I'm
pretty sure is anafi from the motion
picture avatar
look guys y'all know I'm a big homo but
Devon was the most beautiful man I have
ever seen it's good to sack man we're
going full reaches hips down the back
here's that tempo with one two one two
keep it going yep after a couple minutes
just flatlined I thought well only 28
more minutes of this so I'm going to die
always grunting the unifying theme of
all the things we've done are the
strange very unique noises that are
produced by Orion vergara ah this is the
warm-up breath exercise just maintains
you uncomfortable resistance Devon was
great I was really mad at him because at
one point it looked like he wasn't
sweating and I was like how [ __ ] dare
you at least look like you're a little
tired don't be a dick a few minutes into
the workout Stern like changing colors
and I felt like I was in a club oh [ __ ]
the ceiling I'm gonna take it back full
length in four three two one stretch to
stretch to hips down the background okay
there you go it's a dark room where
you're just doing interval training
climbing a ladder forever it's literally
hell I shut my eyes when I was
exercising because I was like if I just
shut out all external stimuli maybe
there's a part of me that can pretend
that I'm this isn't happening
I think the squats were my favorite part
we were doing with a little like ladder
twerk dancing guys I'm not in high
school he can't fail me but I was just
like it's not looking jolly nice you
guys do better when I'm down here it's
going get in a nice sprint down in squat
position moving as fast as you can squat
position
I really like rice nation in the moment
and now I still like it so I think I'll
go back it was one of those things where
I really feel like it was targeting
areas of my body that I've always wanted
to target if I hate a workout it's
because it's a good workout and I hated
it there were definitely times where
it's really got strenuous and I didn't
know if I was gonna make it there was a
moment when I was utterly defeated I
felt like I was gonna throw up and then
I just reached inside and I thought what
would Kobe do did get the most steps so
I've got big dumb giant legs I don't
know how I'm react as Lee came in last
but I did alone him but I think it was
just because I was checking out my butt
so much in America I like skateboarding
and I like walking but I don't like any
other form of exercise I think I think
everyone had a crush on Devin Daysha for
sure had a crush on Devin was a buff
beefcake black Fabio Prince
I'm not Bradley Cooper I never will be
but that day I went the extra mile and I
feel better for it so at the end of the
day it's about hustle and if you're not
here to hustle then why are you here
yeah hell yeah I hustle hustle maniacs
addicted to hustle